ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova
puntata di cucina buttata oggi
cercheremo di trasformare un oreo in uno
reo ora non so voi ma secondo me anche
in cucina le dimensioni contano perché
ho detto anche voglia di mangiar melo
però mi serve come cavia per capire
anche questi geroglifici che non era
piazzarci sopra possiamo far vedere che
è la cappella sistina più semplice per
fare un olio gigante avremo bisogno
intanto degli ingredienti per l'impasto
che sono due punti cioccolato amaro
farina burro 2 uova e del sale che non
deve far vedere sinceramente avrò
bisogno di una bella ciotola e un
cucchiaio una cucchiara del legno
io ringrazio pop sugar per avermi
passato la ricetta perché non avrei
saputo come proseguire altrimenti una
cosa che è molto utile quando si fanno
delle ricette americane è quella di
avere a casa sempre i cosi per le misure
americane perché in america non pesano
usano alle tazze questo io li ho presi
tipo su amazon in un costone manco
troppo in realtà ragazzi quindi
sinceramente vi suggerisco di comprarli
se anche voi volete rovinarvi la
giornata pecchiamo una tazza e mezzo di
farina ma io non ho capito perchè loro
secondo me la farina ai supermercati la
chiudono in modo che nella piega ci sia
della farina che deve
forza cadere ok quest anno fa pagare io
uno sac e sac e sac e sac e sac e sac e
sac e sac e sac e sac e sac e magari
mandare i ragazzi pure questo qua
pazzesco
credo ikea ma è questo fu più utile poi
aggiungiamo lo stesso quantitativo di
cioccolato massimo pazzi si sente giallo
dorino in questo quartiere una tazza e
dopo ciao amore con chi parlare se
tranquillo fallo mentre cucino per noi
non è un problema non è un problema
basta no è il burro e vorrà sempre di
merito puoi fare anch'io ho capito che
ha bisogno di un caffè fatto
tranquillamente mentre voce di questa
casa tua vai fuori area cucina
[Applauso]
mettiamo anche un po di sale un
pizzichino giusto per gradire
ok ma questa era zucchero c'è questa va
beh non l'ho guardato sale ok si è
evidente non sembrava salve
la stampa adesso iniziano ad arrivare i
problemi dati fatto niente di certo è
che è difficile che si sia sposato
esatto più fatto così a muoverlo non
avevo le fruste e quindi ho trovato
questa frusta singola cioè non credo
possa andar bene parte che non ci arriva
ma è normale questo rumore secondo voi
non gira benissimo cosa succede due
tazze di zucchero ma chi è che se magna
durasse legge ma che è ma come si fa a
fare una tazza di burro morbido in the
trees sono le cene di più a chi la
mangia sopravvive
ok dire che può andare come tazza se non
eletto invece sta esagerando con le due
parole con sergio proviamo a usare con
le fruste vai o la va o la spacca
spostiamoci spostiamoci nella mia altra
cucina disco in che contrastare lo
zucchero che cerca di uscire
aggiungiamo a 2 uova 1 e 2
aggiungiamo pian piano questa polvere
intanto devono mischiare mi raccomando
cucchiaio io adesso sto mescolando
sterco cioè senza bisogno di girarci
attorno
aggiungiamo la restante parte cerbo il
trucco argilla nelle mani di uno
scultore o nelle mani di un copro vago
verso il composto che si spiano fra
allora ti spiego cioè nel senso io ti
giuro che te la lavo però cioè quale
cucina non si sporca quando vucinic è
nel senso ma che cucina che cucina e una
cucina che non si sporca quando cucini è
una grande pubblicità prima comprate le
due basi più tutta la roba sopra ma non
ce la posso fare
grandezza media non viene gigantesco
quanto biscotto allora finì verrà il
consiglio
ok non ho più il impronta per poter
sbloccare il mio telefono
certo lei con l'aiuto del coso grazie
anch'io so bravo talmente né panico si
legge cioè si capisce che non so cosa
sto facendo da un bel mattone to calcola
che mangi questo e muori
questo qui è anche un potente veleno ma
ottavio dove quando serve a facilitare
roba vera grazie mille
non sarà gigantesco questore occhiali
non sarà buono però c'è un'altra carta
forno infatti nello ok basta così
proprio quanta se ne serviva questa qui
dobbiamo metterla in frigo un secondo e
poi ci dobbiamo fare le decorazioni mi
dai la pellicola trasparente di breno
grazie di cuore grazie e monsignori a
poche bravo tieni pericolo mentre in
frigo non va beh io provo a metterli
tutti insieme
se sì questo c'è molta più vasta
rispetto a questo però se tu lo analizzi
in realtà quello sono leggermente più
piccolo ma perché c'è una bottiglia
d'acqua in questo lavandino intanto
mettiamo questi qua tipo per una
quarantina di minuti all'interno del
forno a 160 gradi ma non era caldo
ancora
e strano è di plastica è impossibile a
naso
questo è riuscito nella sfida comincia
male
non ci facciamo conduttore del lavoro ok
guardi qua a questo punto di linee di
continuare
l'olio facendo facciamo bene facciamo
nelle lettere no no sbagliato tutto
spetta al partito il forno ok piazziamo
questo qui sopra chissà quanti soldi
sarà questo bottino di pierre fra noi
un tuffo ma perché non un mattarello
perché non c'è e facciamola o reach
amore secondo me quelli è l'olio giusto
in tribunale
ok sono grandi a meno che non uso la
siringa di cioccolato per scrivere
in frigo sir apprenderà tutto passiamo
questo punto all'interno del mega orio
quindi per fare il feeling servirà
zucchero a velo a manetta burro a
manetta della vanillina perché non ho
trovato l'estratto di vaniglia quindi ce
la facciamo andare bene e del latte in
realtà due cucchiai di latte da questo
qui buona per la colazione domani per
prima cosa dobbiamo montare il burro di
nuovo io c'ho sempre sto problema della
tazza di burro e ma non è ancora una
tazza vabbè di burro passiamo alla mia
cucina secondaria si sta schierando la
finale è a questo punto dobbiamo
aggiungere lo zucchero 4 4 di questi
allora aggiungiamo un po di vanillina
una busta
io vedo che schizzano le cose schizzano
nel cielo quattro tazze di zucchero a
velo
[Musica]
questa ricetta è veramente tanto tanto
tanto tanto impegnativa prima pazza
andiamo a sbattere se non è uscito tutto
ok siamo a un'altra pazza sa che sia
cassa anche ragazze che si sta rompendo
non riesce più a resistere allo stress
vabbè andiamo avanti nonostante rotto
non ce ne frega niente dai no
aggiusteremo
aggiungiamo un'altra razza ma sbaglio o
ne perdiamo meta ogni volta che dobbiamo
farla sta cosa che ai quattro buste
davvero un'altra razza di zucchero
staccare a caracalla caracalla adesso
aggiunge looking di latte 12
ok questo era l'ultimo di zucchero lista
credibile che come infilare la testa
nelle tue analisi del sangue
ok non lo vedi che l'angolino
e normale in questo momento provare
questa sensazione si chiama sani
l'azione
prima di tutto non dovremmo arrenderci
secondo dobbiamo creare il ripieno
all'interno che sarà la consistenza sta
roba in frigo ok è arrivato il momento
di comporre il nostro olio questo si sta
spappolando presto sopra poi questo
avrei dovuto fare anche le lettere
troppo tardi ok cui cui questa qui in
cui cui striscetta sono stai proprio per
loro e non c'entra niente
ok mostruoso il nostro giusta e per
fortuna non si mangiavano gli occhi però
ricordiamo sempre con cosa si gli diamo
un po di decorate ok c'è la butta in
caciara sembra stonehenge ok io
purtroppo non avevo la le lettere perché
non c'entravano quindi ho messo dei
simboli pagani all'interno di questo
biscotto però quello che potete vedere è
che è un oreo gigante ci sta però la mia
domanda è ci sento di dargli un morso
no
allora è buonissimo 2020 da questo morso
sto a posto questo l'importo calorico di
cui ha bisogno
1 persona nel giro di dieci anni cioè il
tuo figlio nasce e lo lasci da solo
miracula con questo dà luce un boccone
che ha 18 anni e la patente comunque
ragazzi questa era la ricetta dell'olio
gigante
fatemi sapere se volete farlo anche voi
se vi capita attacca temi sulle vostre
stories sulle vostre foto se posso
dargli un consiglio non provate da casa
non fate mai più noi ci vediamo
naturalmente la prossima domenica con
un'altra puntata di cucina mutata ciao
però mi faccio così uno shottino di
questo conterà camedo mandarla giù dai
menu poco le abbia un defibrillatore
è importante è importante sembra
scrivendo televisioni e normale in un
suggestivo se gianni tu che te ne
pensano i dolci vomiti pervade vomitare
[Musica]
obiettivo nel frigo ha scritto che
subiscono di qualcosa di salato